trois ans qu'il était à l'abandon en
2017 l'ancien centre oecuménique 17 mar
va s'offrir une seconde vie il deviendra
la nouvelle école de musique d'elancourt
construit en 1975 il sera complètement
transformé pour accueillir les 500
élèves de l'actuelle école de musique
jugée inadaptée l'ancienne école de
musique est donc dans la maison de
quartier de la joue où on a un centre
médical certes on a même augmenté le
nombre de stationnements puisqu'on a
fait des aménagements mais il faut
avouer que quand toutes les associations
arrive au même temps au même moment et
que vous avez des gens qui vont au
centre médical impossible de se garer
verbe de temps c'est pas facile non plus
pour sécuriser la dépose des enfants
installés au coeur du centre ville elle
sera donc plus accessible le bâtiment de
730 mètres carrés accueillera une
quinzaine de salles dont six studios une
salle de percussions et une salle
d'audition un projet attendu depuis une
quinzaine d'années sur le plan
architectural le rendu se veut moderne
avec l'utilisation de briques à jour et
vous allez avoir effectivement par
rapport à l'ensemble du bâtiment une
peau qui va entourer le bâtiment aura
une double utilisation isolation
phonique et puis aussi permettre par
rapport en fête au vip vous voyez au
dessus avec les fameuses briques est
qu'ils seront à jour et d'avoir un
éclairage naturel qui rentrera dans le
bâtiment équipé d'une technologie
intelligente l'infrastructure sera le
premier bâtiment domotique d'elancourt
coût des travaux plus de 2 millions
d'euros financés par la ville une
opération qui s'inscrit dans la volonté
d'apporter de l'animation et du
dynamisme sur la dalle 17 mar ouverture
prévue fin 2017